Speed Debating.
Tonight was the final
presidential debate,
thank Christ!
Where the mannequins
from Ann Taylor
and Spencer Gifts--
they duked it out
to win undecided voters.
But we're just not ready
to say good-bye to debates.
So, comedians,
to keep the conflict alive
a little bit longer, I'm gonna
give you a famous issue
and whoever buzzes in first
should weigh in to settle it
once and for all.
First up, cats versus dogs.
Andrew.
Dogs.
'Cause I'm lonely,
but I'm not that lonely.
All right.
-Points. Ben.
-Rebuttal, rebuttal.
-Yeah.
-Cats, because that office chair
-isn't gonna (bleep) on itself.
-Yeah, points. -No.
-He's right. Yes, Adam.
-No. Rebuttal, rebuttal.
Dogs. Cats taste disgusting.
All right, points. Points.
Next up-- I know this is a very
important issue to everyone--
hand jobs versus dry humping.
That looks like kind of
wet humping on the beach though.
-I don't know. Ben.
-Either.
I-I'll take whatever
I can get, at this point.
All right, yeah.
Points to Ben.
Adam.
Hand jobs, because we need
more jobs in this country.
-Yeah, points.
-I'm tired of people
trying to talk
about the non-important issues.
Finally,
someone is on the issues!
I'm mad! I'm fightin' mad!
(cheering and applause)
N-Next one, black versus white.
Black versus white.
Let's be very careful
with this one.
(bleep).
Just hearing...
just hearing one of the three
black dudes in the audience go,
"Yeah, you better be careful."
Uh...
We got this, all right?
We got this.
Adam.
It's black.
Because the darkness comes
for us all.
-Yeah, all right. Points.
-Oh, we can...
we can pretend
it's not wasting our time
with little interactive
Twitter games,
but, eventually,
the black consumes us all.
All right. Good. All right.
Points.